voilà des avis assez partagés justement
sur cette rentrée de 7 en lumière à 2013
elle va se passer comment alors comment
ça va être le premier jour de la rentrée
scolaire je cite toujours quand j'ai
rencontré des gens qui sont pas d'accord
c'est leur droit
c'est la façon dont tu es les frais ni
qui est un peu gênant dans ce corps
qu'on écrit au ministre qu'on supprime
le sport la culture et tous assurent
train et que le seul but c'est de faire
un goûter le vendredi il ya des
dépassements des dépassements de réalité
rue qui concer liens et c'est bien mais
ça c'est dit à bien ce ceci dit ça se
paye
vous souvenez cette gamine que là vous
aviez interrogé d'un moment et c'est
dire inédit
tu sais vraiment peut-être ça va être
super ce qu'on est en train de faire il
convient d enseignants d'ailleurs un
monsieur représentent des enseignants
mais représentent pas les enfants y
compris avec des enseignants nous sommes
en train de préparer vraiment je vous ai
dit tout à l'heure moi je vais pas
recommencer
weeds et des activités culturelles de
découverte de sports d'un conte tissage
et nous avons modifié tous tous les
horaires pour libérer le mercredi matin
et elle est adaptée et si vous saviez
je ne suis pas concerné jusqu'au concert
de même dans ma fonction mais pas
pendant le temps que j'y passe il ya une
adjointe qui mène ça très très bien et
des services et des associations qui se
réunissent régulièrement pour préparer
les activités et elle est ce que ça veut
dire parce que juste juste un mot parce
que nous c'est pas les quatre jours et
demi les week-ends journée c'est bien ça
ils sont positifs mais on en profite
en même temps pour apporter je parle du
périscolaire mais je parle pas du
scolaire ça ne me regarde pas je parle
du périscolaire pour apporter aux
enfants beaucoup plus on embauche 40
éducateurs diplômés papa pas des gens
pour servir un goûter le vendredi dès 40
animateurs diplômés c'est pas pour rien
faire et quand on a réuni jelal
d'association avec une vingtaine quand
on a réuni les associations peut rien
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous apporter
s'associer à d'autres sportifs zonal et
nous avec tout ce dispositif qui est mis
en place
est ce qu'après sept ans mais les
possibilités qui a une réunion à nouveau
de concertation avec des parents
d'élèves et les enseignants il ya ceux
qui sont pour et ceux qui sont impôts
alors moi je rappelle parce que j'ai
excusez moi il ya des choses que qui est
juste nous avons le 3 janvier 2013
j'ai invité tous les directeurs et
l'inspection académique a travaillé et
j'ai l'atout clé tu peux aller écrire
des télés voilà les lettres donc c'est
pas du sénateur est une vérité alors
quand on me dit qu'on m'a pas été
invitée conduire ses affaires
personnelles qui l'attaqué et nous
allons faire en accord avec l'inspection
académique et après j'ajouterai ya donc
un tout petit quelque chose avant de
vous quitter
nous allons en accord avec l'inspection
qui induit que nous allons faire au
moment de la reprise de l'école mais
avant la reprise de l'école deux
journées de travail avec tout ce qui
vole les associations les services de la
ville les enseignants qui le souhaitent
les parents qui le souhaitent et ses 2 2
deux jours n'est bien sûr pas 24 heures
mais deux journées de travail sûres
voilà ce qui est près voilà ce qu'il est
en route parce que nous nous lançons
notre projet d'éducation l'éducation
territoriales et en même temps c'est la
deuxième chose que j'ai en même temps
nous ouvrons trois classes spécifiques
là aussi en accord avec les institutions
académiques avec des personnes qui sont
en formation ensemble de l'éducation
nationale et de la ville
trois classes spécifiques qui accueille
une quinzaine d'enfants de 2 à 3 ans et
les moins de 3 ans
voilà il sait conserver engage elle nous
engage à aménager dans trois écoles des
lieux spécifiques et donc on n'est pas
dans le bricolage croyez moi nicolas
bertrand mesure pour conclure qu est ce
que vous allez entendre que la salle est
mis en place en septembre c'est ce qu'on
aurait souhaité c'est un autre produit
qu'ils ont des mureaux tout à l'heure
aux mureaux il ya un projet derrière il
ya des contenus c'est à dire la maîtrise
du corps la maîtrise de la langue la
citoyenneté excusez moi et justement
nous ce que nous aurions souhaité en
tant qu'enseignant puisque l'objectif
c'était de d'avoir quelque chose qui
puisse être porteur de contenu là on a
mis la charrue avant les boeufs on a mis
des horaires en place s'en soucier de
savoir a priori ce qu'on allait faire
dedans j'aurais quand même rajouter
c'est que sur les 36 écoles et on a
quand même je crois 32 conseil d'école
qui sont quand même les instances où se
discute en concertation avec la mairie
les parents et les enseignants
la vie de l'école qui se sont prononcés
pour demander une concertation ait le
temps d'organiser les choses et non sens
on sent du coup on voit beaucoup en
parler en septembre on va vous
contraindre j'ajouterai que moi aussi
j'ai des lettres et qui on a une j'ai
même pas eu de réponse et du coup on
vient d'en faire un reportage le premier
jour de la rentrée scolaire si vous
autorisez dans une école de trappes pour
moi comment ça se passe on sera étonné
mais revu senna mais j'ai tout arrêté
parce qu'on est un peu trop long merci
en tout cas pour moi d'être d'être venu
en plateau pour parler des rythmes
scolaires merci à vous il faut une
émission entière vous avez raison mais
c'est encore un petit peu en plateau